Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
Deadpool 3 video Hugh Jackman talking about the
plot during the movie I'm sure Kevin feige the
Marvel snipers are totally after him now but
he revealed a bunch more about the actual plot so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch of Easter
eggs and it explains how they're involving the
Loki series and a lot of those characters the TV
ages in general if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up like Loki season
two I just did a new trailer video for the footage
they released for that in Deadpool 3 just in
general gonna be a huge Crossover with the events
of the Loki series although Loki season 2 will
Premiere a long time before Deadpool 3 comes out
so the events of Deadpool 3 will take place well
after the events of Loki season 2. but here's Hugh
Jackman talking about how this crosses over with
some of the things during the Loki series because
you know it's science and and so I don't have to
screw with the Logan timeline which was important
to me and I think probably to the fans all because
of this device they have in the Marvel world of
moving around timelines now we can go back as you
can tell he's explained the plot of the movie he's
sensing Kevin feige the Marvel snipers have their
guns trained on him like oh this is how Wolverine
is going to die his final death Kevin feige is
going to be the person to take care of him and
it's because he gave away the plot of Deadpool
3. doing his very best to join the spoiler Bros
but the clip actually does a pretty good job of
explaining what they're actually doing during
the movie like we already knew it was going
to be a big Loki series Crossover with the
TVA Miss minutes the Mobius character hopefully
Deadpool will help him get that jet ski and even
though they were being very tongue-in-cheek
and jokey about the way they were revealing
things in that earlier trailer they still tried
to explain some of the plot but there's still
been a big question about some of the details
like they're not completely throwing out any of
the pre-existing Canon from the earlier Fox Marvel
movies and obviously this is going to be a younger
version of Wolverine than we saw during the Logan
movie even the events of the Wolverine origin
movie are still Canon tool Wolverine's timeline
the X-Men movies but they're using Deadpool 2's
post-credits scene and him messing around with
Cable's time travel device and saying that when he
did that like when he kills the other version of
himself the other Deadpool from Wolverine Origins
he starts creating a bunch of Nexus events and
also what they're doing is saying that some of
those movies but not all of them but a few of them
took place in alternate timelines for example the
events of Wolverine Origins is a Deadpool variant
of the main version like the main version is the
one that we see in Deadpool and Deadpool 2. and
during all those post-credits scenes he's just
jumping around in the timeline of the fox Marvel
movies messing around with history creating Nexus
events like him killing a version of himself
earlier in his timeline is meant to be another
timeline it's meant to be another variant of
himself but the whole idea is that he's killing
a version of himself before that Ryan Reynolds had
a chance to make the first Deadpool movie erasing
Deadpool's future existence creating a huge Nexus
event which would put him on the TVA list another
good example of that is him messing with Baby
Hitler in that last post-credit scene like that
would create a huge Nexus event and if it wasn't
clear during Deadpool 2 they canonized that
version of Deadpool's the main version as Canon 2
the Main X-Men movies the first class movies and
during X-Men Days of Future Past they canonized
the first class movies to the original X-Men movie
saying that was all part of the same timeline but
when we start talking about the Logan movie even
though that's meant to be the distant future like
a very post-apocalyptic version of the future of
Wolverine's timeline the X-Men movies technically
that is meant to take place in yet another
timeline so that's why Hugh Jackman In that clip
says oh we have this device it's basically like a
TVA Time Pad level device where they can jump
around different timelines avoiding the Logan
timeline like specifically the Logan movie that
he calls out because they are messing with the
timeline of the main X-Men movies a bunch like
he literally says going back in time that's him
explaining being the younger version of Wolverine
during the events of the movie and basically as
I've said before Deadpool 3 is supposed to be
a version of Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but they're doing it more like Deadpool destroys
the fox Marvel Universe I don't think they would
actually be legit enough to put kill in a movie
title like Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
will be the greatest movie title of all but
they'll probably swerve on that just a little
bit like Deadpool destroys the Marvel universe or
something similar to that and because he's mostly
destroying the fox Marvel movies like that's part
of the big joke like messing with the fox Marvel
timelines they're supposed to have a bunch of
funny cameos from across all the fox Marvel
movies like anything that was made under Fox's
watch not just the main X-Men movies like the
original Fantastic Four movies there's even been
talk of Chris Evans doing a very short Cameo as
his original Johnny Storm character he's already
joked about actually being game to do something
like that like that would actually be pretty cool
there have even been rumors about them doing a
version of galactopool I don't know if they'll
wind up eventually doing that because you'd have
to explain who Galactus is to explain who Galactic
pool is if you haven't read those Comics he's
just from an alternate universe version of the
evil Deadpool core and he just shows up being a
version of Galactus looking like Deadpool they
didn't fully explain his backstory but you can
see how Deadpool messing with the TVA Time Pad
device jumping around the timeline messing with
things creating a bunch of Nexus events leading
to complete chaos in all the timelines would lead
to something like galactopol like they'll just
say oh Deadpool messed things up so badly that
it led to something like a version of Galactus
who is Deadpool you also have to remember that
the movie's not going to come out for a couple
years so we might have seen a teaser for an actual
version of Galactus before that I just did a Thor
love and thunder video about a deleted scene where
they had a version of Thor fighting a version of
Galactus inside the main MCU timeline so they've
already had a lot of conversations about trying
to work Galactus into Marvel movies before but
the main way they're pulling all these cameos off
as Hugh Jackman says is that either Cable's time
travel device is already based on TVA timepad
technology those devices that Kane created that
manipulate Quantum energy allowing the TVA agents
to open portals across time and space or when the
TVA arrests Deadpool and Wolverine and holes them
into the TBA he just steals a Time Pad device off
of one of them the way that Loki stole a Time
Pad device and then they start jumping around
the fox Marvel timelines and that's how they have
all these other characters from those movies show
up in cameos the one thing we don't totally
know yet is why Deadpool continues to do that
like how does Wolverine become part of this plot
like why is Deadpool continuing to mess with all
these different timelines we know why he started
to do that during Deadpool too in the post credit
scene he wanted to save Vanessa's life that
was the whole point the rest of the post-credit
scenes were him just cleaning up some of his
quote-unquote Messes in the past Hugh Jackman also
posted another clip where he revealed even more
I'm sure Kevin feige got even more upset about
this where he talks more about the actual plot in
a clear way but if I'm honest 20 minutes into that
Deadpool movie all I kept saying was 48 Hours the
McNulty Eddie Murphy movie and I was like damn it
damn it what have I done what have I done no you
said no that's it it's done okay when he compares
the plot of Deadpool 3 to the 48 Hours movie
that's an Eddie Murphy Nick Nolte buddy cop movie
where they're basically like two cops that team
up to chase down and arrest a couple criminals
because it was an Eddie Murphy movie it was very
comedic like the Deadpool movies are very comedic
in tone so it's basically Hugh Jackman calling
Deadpool 3 a buddy cop movie but it's Wolverine
and Deadpool teaming up to take down some people
they haven't fully revealed who the actual
villains of the movie are supposed to be but
during the Deadpool 3 trailer video Ryan Reynolds
released a while ago they did have a jokey moment
where they kind of reveal the plot of the movie
but they're that funny George Michael voice over
that's actually been decoded since then this is
what they're actually saying during that part of
the clip so basically what they're saying is that
Deadpool winds up finding a version of Wolverine
when he jumps back in the timeline they fight each
other and because they both have a healing factor
it's sort of like the immovable object meets the
Unstoppable force and they just hack each other to
pieces for a little while and it turns into this
funny thing until eventually they just get tired
of laying into each other and then eventually
team up to take down some bigger criminals so at
least the beginning of the movie It's Deadpool
versus Wolverine or Wolverine vs Deadpool however
you want to think about it but then ultimately
them teaming up to face a larger villain and then
having to jump across the timeline to chase them
down based on some of the casting announcements
there's a rumor that Danger from the X-Men Comics
is going to be the villain or one of the villains
because zoom and enhanced she was actually the
main villain of that Deadpool comic book that Ryan
Reynolds was reading on the can in the Deadpool
costume during the trailer that he released danger
is basically like the anthropomorphized version
of the training facility the danger room just
given physical form eventually gaining a level of
sentience and turning into a villain that doesn't
really explain what she's doing in the movie that
would cause Deadpool to try and chase her across
the timeline across the fox Marvel movie timeline
to try and stop her but it sounds like it's one
of those situations where Deadpool is trying to
be the good guy but in doing so he's jumping
around the timeline creating a bunch of Nexus
events trying to chase this person in in the TVA
like Mobius Miss minutes are all chasing Deadpool
down trying to stop him from continuing to create
Nexus events I am sure Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds
will continue to release videos talking about the
movie they'll be filming for a lot of next year so
we'll get a bunch more details we'll actually see
some footage from the set really soon everybody
who's making the movie Kevin feige Bob Iger CEO
of Disney again now the director Ryan Reynolds
himself Hugh Jackman have all promised that the
movie will still be rated R it'll still be in
the tone of what you would expect from a Deadpool
movie even though it will be part of the Marvel
Universe and that's because of the involvement
The Crossover with the TVA the Loki characters
I'm not expecting any kind of Deadpool Cameo
scene during Loki season 2 though like I said
Loki season 2 episodes happening really soon
Deadpool 3 not happening for a couple years so
I don't know if Loki himself or a version of Loki
or one of his variants will show up in Deadpool 3.
like Deadpool and Wolverine get hauled into the
TVA get arrested by them and you see a version
of Loki walking around in the background and
everyone click here for that new Loki season
2 trailer video that just released and click
here for my full Loki trailer video from earlier
this year thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!